good afternoon to everybody so I prefer
to start all our meetings in time
because what's in yells students are
coming slowly from around the campus so
let's start sharp and it's a big
privilege for me to welcome exceptional
personality with the fantastic
diplomatic political career and now in
the United Nations the German ambassador
German permit representatives to United
Nations dr. Christopher Costigan who
despite his tough schedule in the
Security Council as well well he found
the time to visit us and to share on his
country vision on the future of United
Nations of the future of Europe dr.
Hauschka is exact person to share with
us on all these issues because the
biggest part of his kill career he spell
it for European affairs he was any team
drafting and pushing the the treaties of
the European Union he was in the
Commission on the arms control and then
he was advisor to the minister kinkle
and what is more important that for the
last 13 years he was the the top person
in the team of Chancellor Merkel on the
foreign policy and security so
ambassador house gain knows the details
he will try to encourage him to share
with us on these details
knowing that ambassadors they are so
limited in the openings but we have a
good excellent moderator today dr. Tom
Graham senior fellow from the Jackson
Institute and the the Acting Director of
the Kissinger Foundation
well and I hope that Tom will put the
exact question well to satisfy our
expectations here well with that made me
to invite ambassador housing and well to
address you and his vision and then
we'll come back to well to the questions
and answers thank you very much thank
you
thank you very much for the introduction
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak here today I have to correct
you at the very beginning and I'm taking
time out from my calendar but not from
the Security Council because we are not
in the Security Council at least yet and
but I come to that I come to that yes
but thanks very much for for for being
here actually it's mine my first visit
to university I tried to come here
earlier and that was during my time as a
student studied actually in Switzerland
and at the time I applied for a
scholarship and I got a scholarship from
the Rotary Foundation the Rotary
Foundation gave you a possibility to to
to choose or to tell them which
universities you wanted to go to so I
put Ivy League universities and and Yale
there and then I ended up at Georgia
Southern College in Statesboro Georgia I
had a wonderful wonderful year it was
really wonderful year to be to be in
Georgia and I've been back here 40 years
later actually over Easter to to that
area that's wonderful but it's not Yale
so it's very I'm very happy to be here
to be here today to talk to you about
the future of the United Nations the
future of the of the of the European
Union and I can say that for us the
forum politics the UN and the EU are on
the top of our priority list and why is
that
you have to go back to John's history to
understand why un why the you are is so
important for for Germany because as you
all know until 1945 in particular the
years before Germany didn't know the
rule of law we had Hitler period we had
Nazi time and we all know what Germany
cost in in Europe and and and Beyond and
after the Second World War it was very
clear and the Allies made it very clear
that Germany should never again behave
as it did before in the 30s and 40s and
at the same time also democracy rule of
law a civil way to resolve crises it's
deeply rooted in internment toast war
generations and this combination that
the Allies were very firm this actually
when we had our when we wrote our
Constitution the Dragon Constitution it
was had to be checked by the Allies and
they wanted to see that actually
democracy is firmly rooted in this in
this constitution and that democracy the
rule of law freedom of media the the
individual rights are firmly rooted in
in the in the Constitution and when you
go back in in German history now 20-30
years actually the green movement for
instance the movement of of civil
society had its roots in in in Germany
we have today still a strong Green Party
a party representing views of civil
society so for us the rule of law
democracy are very very important
and at the same time for us the European
Union is as important it's kind of the
the other side of the of the coin German
democracy but then also in Europe in
Europe before the the First World War
the Second World War
what ruled was not a situation where you
went by by law but it was the country
the politician a government that thought
it would be strongest and had the best
army and and then over Germany
particular then it what is it and this
should never happen again and therefore
the founding fathers of the of the
European Union Konrad Adenauer and
Germany and Robert Schumann and others
they for them it was very important that
no longer in the future will be we
resolve the problems between our
countries by force but we want to
resolve it by the rule of law and this
is what the European Union is beautiful
when you have today a meeting of any
body of the European Union the European
Council the Council of Ministers working
groups there is always a representative
of the of the legal department present
in the in in the meetings and he's quite
frequently he or she is quite nearly
referred to and has to give his or her
opinion of what ministers or civil
servants are just about to decide is
this in conformity with the European law
and one of the most influential
strongest institutions in the you
in union is the European Court of
Justice so therefore the rule of law the
the lessons of what the lessons of the
terrible time led to the Second World
War has its conclusion had its
consequences in what Germany tries to
represent of we're also a European
stands for and I come to the United
Nations and this is the same thing the
United Nations is of course was the
result of the Second World War and were
the Alliance after the second war said
well this what happened before must not
happen again and therefore we set up the
United Nations and Germany which came
out became only member in 1973 we have
always been supportive to the UN we have
been in the Security Council of the
United Nations every eight years we try
to contribute to the to the UN this is
where the one organization where each
and every country of this world is
represented 193 countries and this is
where important decisions have been been
taken when you look at all the different
conventions resolutions agreements that
have been closed worldwide this have
been under UN auspices and we think it's
it's very important to promote this even
if and we just live through the a period
again where within the Security Council
there are more disagreements and they
are agreements but nevertheless the UN
is the most for us the most important
body global body and we need to support
this so for us it is it is key we have
right now and two years ago the UN
General Assembly adopted the stds
sustainable development goals which are
actually
objectives the world community has set
itself to achieve by 2030 in the
different areas that that are important
for mankind for all continents for for
all people so it is important for
Germany actually in 2016 this is the
latest figure I have Germany was the
second contribute contributor to the UN
system us number one and and Germany
number two it has to do with the fact
that we have been supportive the core
budget but also number of organizations
that belong to the UN family like the
World Food Program units F that are very
importantly UNDP that are very important
for us so and having said that you will
you will you will understand that for
somebody who for whom the UN is very
important and for whom at the same time
also for my personal background I was I
spent five years before I came here all
together in my life in the US
transatlantic relations are key for for
me personally because also its thanks to
the to the United States that Germany
after the second world war got back on
its feet with the Berlin Airlift with
support for our Constitution with then
the support we had in 1989 when it came
to reunification
so of course and I'm very frank yet it
hurts when you have your colleague at
the UN nikki Haley last week say that
she shares John Bolton's disdain for the
UN so this is something which of course
is something that you wonder why it said
and and you try to understand and you
try to talk and I come back to us
positions
in in a minute so for Germany the rule
of law is is very important for its
history but also for the experience in
the last 70 years also to add that when
I said we have been always promoting the
European Union we think the the model of
European Union is something that is
worthwhile also for other regions to
have really countries in the region
joined forces and and represent
themselves so Germany has always been
supportive
starting with ASEAN we have been
supported for Mirko Sewer for the Gulf
Cooperation Council we have been
promoting the last years in particular
the African Union actually the seat of
the African Union Addis Abeba
you have a situation where we have the
the so called peace and security
building it's financed by it was
financed by Germany because we think
this regional currents are very
important so for us and this is the
general theme for us we are in favor of
a rules-based international order and
this is something that we want to
promote and that we are promoting and if
countries are not following this we also
criticize and I must say that when you
look at the present situation we are in
a situation where the the rule of law
the International rules-based order is
under severe strain and it's not only to
please our Ukrainian Ukrainian hosts
here and that I start with Russia and
with the fact that Russia during the
last years has severely under mined the
rules-based international order in my
previous job as national security
advisor for Chancellor Merkel I spent
the last four years most of the time
most of the time but vast amount of time
on the Ukraine crisis and
and I remind everybody when also in my
country say well about Crimea when it
was a bit dubious and well actually
belonged to Russia anyway so why don't
you accept that Russia is now owning so
to speak Crimea and I tell people that
no actually this is a very severe breach
of the international rules-based order
why in 1994 and you must have told this
of course dear students but in 1994
Ukraine gave up the nuclear weapons that
were in this territory and in exchange
Britain US and Russia guaranteed in
writing in the Budapest memorandum
guaranteed national sovereignty
territorial integrity of of Ukraine and
there is no doubt that Crimea belongs to
to to to Ukraine
people believe well actually it's part
of Russia and there is even no
Geographic natural link between Russia
and Ukraine the net only natural link is
to Ukraine it was systematically linked
to Ukraine and when after the after the
Soviet Union fell apart there were poles
they were votes in Ukraine about to to
go independent or not and even on Crimea
a majority was in favor of going to to
become independent so so this invasion
of Crimea the crisis that remains in
Donbass is something which is really
undermining international law and this
is not the only thing our Russian
partners and you follow this right now
and have defend Syria and defend a
regime that is undermining international
noise undermining humanitarian law and
you have seen what the allegations
against Russia what they did in England
on Salus parenthese was
the the only incident and what is
happening also on cyberattacks for the
last 10 years I still remember 10 years
ago when Estonia was almost paralyzed
that since then Russia has has
systemically
used cyber war to undermine countries
and even in in one of my favourite areas
which is sports the Russia
systematically violates international
sport through even by advice by from the
from the state when you see that the
doping system it's actually managed by
the this is the Minister for sports so
Russia is something is a it's a
challenge China is a challenge China is
becoming more and more more important
you follow probably also what is
happening in the area the South China
Sea where you where China is also
systematic systematically violating
international law the law of the sea
when you look at China itself in
domestic politics you see how it
violates also the humanitarian Human
Rights conventions dealing with
minorities dealing with lawyers dealing
with journalists dealing with with NGOs
and what happened three weeks ago in the
National Congress when presidency was
then invited so to speak no longer to
limit his mandate we even go back to
reform that thanks yelping I think then
introduce and that is that the president
should have only limited terms and then
should be replaced in
kind of it in kind of a democratic way
but should be replaced by somebody else
so China is going into a into a
direction with regard to also this
prolongation of presidencies which we
have in other countries we have that in
in Africa and in Burundi we have it in
Rwanda we have it in Congo even Russia
didn't go that far President Putin after
two times as president when this Prime
Minister and then came back so at least
the the Constitution was adhere to so
backsliding from the rule of law we have
this in unfortunately in many areas we
are following with concern what is
happening in our in Europe with our NATO
partner Turkey I until today I have not
heard a reasoning which I can follow for
the intervention in a free when you look
at the domestic situation the rule of
law when you see how systemically the
judicial system was undermined Turkey is
the country with the highest number of
journalists in in prison when you look
at how the media freedom is undermined
it makes you it makes you very nervous
we can go around the world Philippines
was also a democratic country where the
rule of law was and when you look today
at the way that to turtle and implements
its legal system you get headaches
Myanmar you all follow this UN Special
Representative or plant for Human Rights
has described what happened to the
Rohingya is genocide and and we have
discussed before so I mentioned Syria so
what is happening there also is of
course against the rule of law and
unfortunately and I have to come back to
host country to the u.s. there has also
been some from my perspective were in
developments I mentioned the remark that
nikki Haley made last week I received a
email buyer in December when in the
security and the General Assembly the
resolution was on the agenda about
president Trump's decision to move the
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem and
so I shipped a message from my colleague
and she said well we want you to vote
against this resolution and if you don't
vote for this resolution I will report
you to the to the President and I
Germany voted yes and I had a long
conversation with her afterwards to to
explain to her that you know and this
was the mail that I received her was
something that I was very sad about
because actually it was against what the
Americans had always told us you know
you have to go by the rule of law and I
explained to her there is a Security
Council resolution 4 7 8 a binding
resolution where the US at time
abstained where it is said no Embassy
should go to your room and those
embassies in Jerusalem and there were
actually some 17 embassies in the 60s
there should move senators should should
move out so she asked me to actually
violate international law so this is
something that we we regret we regret
that the u.s. is leaving the Paris
agreement that the u.s. president Trump
has and is on the verge of actually now
leaving the Iran nuclear deal Iran
nuclear deal which is from the nuclear
watchdog in in Vienna said that Iran is
at
into this deal I mean I don't say
anything about the Iranian behavior in
the region but this deal they adhere to
and by then saying that this is not
happening then and and if the US would
would leave the Iran deal this would
again be something where say well there
is an agreement that was taken between
the UN six countries and us just just
leaving it the disrespect for the World
Trade Organization and something that is
very worrying I must say though I became
a national security adviser in 2005 one
of the first issues we had also with the
then government Bush was Guantanamo
where we also told a lot of American
friends this is something where we
believe yes should observe international
law and this is not in accordance with
the international maturing law so having
a president criticizing the fake news
and thank New York Times and faking a
CNN something where we believe the the
freedom of medium of the media of the
press is something actually sacred and
this is also something which which hurts
and criticism and we have been following
this these last days a criticism of the
you dishes system it's also something
for you know in a democratic country
where you have the division of powers is
something that you are not very happy
about so what are the consequences all
of this you know having listed all the
negative developments one would say well
you know why don't you give up Germany
and maybe I'm too old and not open
enough for other for other alternatives
Germany will defend and do everything to
defend international rules-based order
and this is also why we are campaigning
for the Security Council
we have in June votes to go into Syria
for two years we want to see that as
member of the Security Council we can do
and contribute to the implementation of
what we what we what we sent stand for
in general we worked very hard to reform
the Security Council and they reformed
the UN we support secretary-general
Guterres in his efforts to reform the
organization and we are also in favor as
I sent two to reform the Security
Council let me go back to to the
European Union and I told you at the
very beginning that for us after the
second world war with our Chancellor
Konrad Adenauer who was kind of a hero
of my childhood that we were always in
favor of strengthening the European
Union we know that there are challenges
when I turned and criticized other
continents countries I also have to
criticize within the European Union some
member countries what is happening in
Hungary and what is happening in Poland
with regard to the freedom of media also
with respect for the judiciary this is
something that is very negative and we
support the European Union in particular
our commissioner Tim Allen who is
working on this intro implementing and
trying to get European rules implemented
but I must say that the European Union
also that those who wrote the and agreed
upon the treaties never thought that
what for us was was basic in Europe
democracy rule of law today could be put
into question by members in the European
Union who when they became members like
the East Europeans had to fulfill the
so-called Copenhagen criteria where the
rule of law democracy was fully
enshrined so we have our negative
developments but still we have a lot of
populism in Germany we have right-wing
parties also in my country I could
imagine with our history that we would
have a right-wing party which in recent
policy has on 30 and 14% so what do we
have to do we have of course as in the
u.s. you have to see to it that you look
after the concerns of the people of the
concerns of every people not only often
as a certain very educated class but you
have to look at the grass you have to
see what are they concerned about they
are concerned about security in Europe
now many are concerned about immigration
and you have to see to it that you
resolve that that you that you see that
in internal security this is given you
have to look at external security and of
course you have to be sure that there
are enough jobs created therefore one of
the issues during the whole euro crisis
which was always very important for the
transfer she was criticized very much
for this was always to see to it that
the countries in crisis would not get
unlimited amount of financial support
but that they had to undergo reforms
because in globalization we need to have
economies in Europe that are competitive
within Europe outside Europe to create
jobs to see that there is a there is a
future in globalization because I don't
think that you can close your doors and
and cannot and participate in in
globalization so it is very important
that internal security close control of
outer borders external security actually
when you conduct polls in Europe you'll
find that it's wrong majority is in
favor of a current foreign security
policy of Europe so we have to go into
into into this direction and as
we have to be competitive and there I
come back to what was very important at
the outset of the European Union when we
had President Charlie goal and France
and and Carano in Germany they see it
the German French French partnership
relationship and this German French
couple has always worked and we are I
say very happy about president Mac home
in France and who is right now facing
some criticism for his reform process in
in France but we wish in every lucky we
want him to be successful we want French
economy to be successful when the French
and German we aren't sync and I think
that will be the basis also for
strengthening of the of the of the
European Union which we believe very
very highly we had in in Berlin the day
before yesterday and actually today
retreat of the cabinet of the new
cabinet of the new ministers took a long
time to form a coalition this time and
the Chancellor in our press conference
afterwards this morning said the most
important issue for us is Europe so this
you see that this remains a priority for
us let me go back to to transatlantic
relations here I worked for many years
with my counterparts in Washington and
we had a very good very good
relationship including with the outgoing
Security Advisor McMaster and he wrote a
piece together with Cohn and economic
advisor both are gone aji they wrote a
piece in The Wall Street Journal half a
year ago where they described the world
as an arena and you have to fight within
the
in the arena and it's kind of a lose win
situation and my argument with the mo
synthesis also the remark I want to
close with and I think you know
transatlantic relations global relations
there is still hope for it for a win-win
situation there are in all areas you can
come to agreements where both sides in
the end are winners and and this will be
also something that we will try to work
on in case we are voted into the
Security Council so thank you very much
for the invitation thanks very much for
listening and now we go into a
discussion
[Music]
it was from the wackiness and sorry for
forgiveness of course NATO has been
instrumental in preserving peace in the
post-war area era and we have of course
after 89 the question was well what is
the what is the importance of NATO and
then then we saw after September
September 11 and then Afghanistan then
with what I mentioned the invasion of
Russia of Ukraine threats also against
the Baltic countries and their NATO has
come again to to play a very
so I was contradicting more of a need to
cross the place a place are we are we
are criticized for not living up to the
support 2% goal you would come to that
so I do a preemptive right here and
jokingly always say I hope for the next
big recession in Germany because then
you can quickly reach serious we have
been increasing our expenditure but
let's say that the last 10 years we have
had constant GDP so even but it raising
defense the defense budget we have only
minimally closer to 2% we have a
coalition government it is extremely
difficult
I'm a member of the Christian Democrat
Party to commit
Social Democratic friends to to agree to
these kind of places you need to get
there and the last coalition agreement
has something very interesting there is
a compromise said that when we come to
and be a path that these last year's
budget surpluses we have in Germany then
the money will be spent evenly on
development policy and our military
because we deeply believes that there is
no crisis no conflict this world that
you can resolve with military means
alone so you can of course go at bomb
and then you go out and then you have
the big mess and then you have
terrorists coming up so you always have
to go go in and see to it that you know
and when it comes down to the OTAs of
the development assistance actually we
were we met
that's your the year before we actually
met the intention of 0.7 percentage gold
which had to do a lot with the refugees
that be accepted oh but far beyond party
being reelected like several more years
of this going on for five years now as
well what is the European Union doing at
this point it gives you confidence that
eventually bringing both hungry and
pulled back to something that would
empower the baby see as as your
a very good question I hardly entered
try to answer it I think that in the end
and Europe such would not be is why
because Europe we are still sovereign
nations and by the European Union the
commercial area with venturi so when you
have the the also certain within the
internal market they don't correspond
then you go to the Court of Justice then
the ruling is majority of cases
everybody that hears when it comes to
issues that you raise I mentioned when
the judiciary is weakened when the media
the first thing that happened
angry yesterday was that the opposition
newspapers just so what can you do
I think I think at the end test account
of the countries themselves Poland is
the country were actually much of what
happened in Eastern Europe we had the
common ancestors started with solar
panels we all do and the second and I
just cannot imagine that the Polish
society was stood up against the Soviet
Union was actually started to get rid of
they are ready to go back to come to to
the situation where you have
freedom media etc of course and what we
have to do in our countries and this is
also something observer but you have to
see the one hand in the US also you have
New York we have you have Moscow but you
have the landscape you have the villages
of signed and some suffer more others
are the biggest benefits from European
system so that's still out in Hungary
and same thing all - actually much
further in his efforts to see to it I
think he said himself I want to have a
liberal democracy somewhere he has
streamlined and of course the opposition
in Hungary when you go back to the
Socialists they never really broke with
the communist parties at the
the problem and then I was able to to
split the opposition still I have enough
repetition you're a good friend of
George Soros who is there who has been
and the way the Soros was used in the
election campaign it's incredible so
what is my hope I hope it said other
societies young generations
[Music]
more consistent with what you would like
to see how funny or less outside Western
Balkans received I think greater
attention over over the past several
months has part because the sense that
instability concerns but also think
there's a sense in Europe let be the
Western Balkans and we had a tremendous
push in the nineteen nineties quitting
process and then lost interest what is
the policy now the German government
on western borders if and you have to do
right we we had to follow up the rubric
part of the Balkan
and after Dayton after Kosovo crisis and
people said okay now
we can turn back into into our internal
affairs and then at the same time the
early 2000s which was the natural
process of finishing process to these so
everybody was concentrated the Baltic
countries the digital countries Cyprus
Wallis and and you one decision was
taking in 1999 this is the key decision
I'm not even sure that we could take it
today there was the European Council in
Thessaloniki in 1999 where all the
warheads countries who are given the
European perspective so all of these
countries sometimes for instance right
now the European is not ready to give to
countries like Ukraine or Georgia to the
same extent giving it to the borders
- region
the advancement of work so but on the
board's net so this is one thing and
then and the Chancellor four years ago
saw exactly what you said she then
started the so-called burden process
where once per year all the and heads of
government come together in countries
including Kosovo where they discuss
among each other with joining the
European Union and that we have a
serious now we had it Austria Italy
Britain this year and and there is a
so-called burden process and we started
economic cooperation between them we
have now French Academy of Sciences
working together and so we we are
working with the former IRA mentor for
European foreign policy the European
foreign minister so to speak Cathy
Ashton engaged so there is focus on the
countries still they need to reform and
the problems that we have in these
countries again we have to work on this
but we have to pay attention because
other countries are awaiting our Russian
partners are and in the rating service
there
to degrade Macedonia and so we have to
be very active it should be also
something very effective so European
Union has to be it has to be present we
also have to get used more and more to
the fact that our marionettes are the
days of Holbrook who single-handedly
solved some of the problems and we
Europeans were not able to do it needed
the Americans today and we don't have
the broad consent boy in the State
Department one of the administration
lost his job and so there's of course I
do accept that Europe has to resolve the
Commons continent but you know us
support maybe
Durov state this would again be on the
agenda negotiating with Montenegro
Serbia at the yes or the birch we are
pushing very much shelter that's
idumaean a nice issue that lets you to
know we are present but I must admit a
few conducted and posted in Europe what
are we gonna I mean we all know that
I mean law society
you see I join this area we with you
that we have a difference of use and
let's say during the time I was
responsible in the chancellor's office
for the so convinced process in the
negotiations with together with my
colleagues with Ukraine and Russia for
that letter and there was Toria Nuland
was the assistant secretary and we an
excellent cooperation and early on to
continue this cooperation and perform
was nominated
solution administration and he does a
remarkable job and and we are actually
so no complaints whatsoever I think this
is very good our Russian partners sought
at some stage to drive a wedge between
us there no we have to we have to stay
with our principles we have to know if
we have to stand to this and be very
clear and sections held at the same time
we always have to talk
we always have to see is there a
possibility to find a solution
I never thought five years ago that one
of the european cities with no best by
the end of my time as national security
advisor would be myths because I went
there many times for these negotiations
even if it was if it didn't yield a lot
but it was very important to sit at a
table to see can we can we find can we
find common ground and can we move
forward so we should always continue to
do that and I always believed that
Europe and Russia are two certainly
[Music]
natural partners if you can work
together we had offered the number of
partnership agreements wanted to engage
in this but then people would be
underestimated was the fact that the end
of the Soviet Union which was many
beginning of a paradise by
poutine was seen as a as he has said
that biggest catastrophe
Julianne's of this pride and then his
ambition to actually recreate soil too
late but we're then always said well why
didn't you have to give an association
agreement to Ukraine and so why don't
you accept that Ukraine is Reggie there
are less say we as drugs who brought so
much so much terror so much suffering to
two countries like Ukraine who want me
to tell you credits are you a real
gravity in the wrong place you can not
have an association with European what
maybe we have done at the time but
you're a better place to say that maybe
harder to see a bit in economic union
but nevertheless in the end it's all
about the choice of the people and we
all need to tell you
Iranian citizen so I think this is what
we have to understand they understand
and we have to represent but at the same
time and that's a rusher who was this
resources huge country there's so much
possibility to work together 27
along with other
ever met Barton but this for a solver
that same day determining the final
permit to begin construction of the
North Spring which he proposed
[Music]
increasing European dependence on
Russian gas resources and also undermine
two different elements in mind easy
answer to get first for let me living in
more general Germany and Russia have
always had in history a closer closer
some less closer such a complicated
sometimes less complicated history and
Germany brought I was talking about what
happened in Ukraine when you look at
victims victims in Russia were also the
[Music]
last German and more prisoners out and
the Cold War there was a deal with
Russia on some steel pipe lines so there
was always this relationship and and
within the German government when you
have one party that is spending more for
this for for Chancellor of Germany and
fula today is in the board of law
so you see that this is part of so when
the North stream to decision came up and
the trencher
they said well we see this as it was
this is a commercial undertaking if it's
in it is compatible with EU laws we will
not be joined and so so we went through
the EU procedure we now are the other
countries from the 40 countries to speak
they have to see and we are not for
those who are in favor of this pattern
we are not there yet at the same time
also in the retreat of the cabinet the
transfer said press conference this
morning that of course we have to have
solution where transit gas traveling
through the grain
so that Ukraine would continue I must
say one thing because criticize us for
this I would love that
no American and there are big American
companies gasps why don't you look into
the possibility of gas terminal and
there's one to Germany's biggest energy
market why not get Exxon or something
building the terminal for a dignified
and to Europe space is clearly
considering military actions at this
point where is the German government
office would you be supportive of a
military option at this point and would
you actually participated to deal with
the obviously is the violation and the
chemical weapons
his complicity what is a horrifying
humanitarian disaster we are when you
look at the humanitarian situation in
Syria you can see how Russia you know
participating or allowing Syrian forces
to treat its own population the way it
does so there needs to be an
international response the United States
and allies try very hard to get Security
Council to move on this and develop
yesterday was 12 votes they abstain and
so what what needs to be done and when
you look I mentioned before the
iterative the rule of law and what is
then for a military intervention with a
legal basis for this and we are very
stay nicely there
to protect we go back to to the
situation in Kosovo
okay
[Music]
discussion about humanitarian
connections and because and I think that
legal advisors when they look at the
situation great and great hair so on
this first of all Germany will not
participate because for a military
intervention we need to vote of
Parliament and in our Constitution it is
written that you can only use use force
when you do this either on the night
date of the UN NATO or you do it on
article 51 but none of that would be
given so Germany for legal reasons
cannot on the other hand just to see
this happening and when you see these
pictures this is just horrible so I
think there would be political
understanding for all of you that see if
you have any questions if you do please
raise your hand you can identify
yourself they have a microphone over
your goodies that's when we made the
microphone
and we just state your name right thank
you
my name is Mito Mardan I'm a dual
citizen Federal Republic of Germany and
United States of America two topics you
haven't mentioned brexit so what are
your thoughts how that drama is going to
come to a conclusion the other topic
that I would like to hear your thoughts
is what is the story of this two-speed
Europe
now that the viz across member states
basically are only interested in the
dissemination of funds and perhaps the
single market why not force the
two-speed Europe okay thank you yes
that's it I think it will happen I don't
think that the British people will come
back on that decision
I hope that the negotiations will come
out in a way where you have an amicable
divorce which also means that you Great
Britain will not be just any third
country but that Britain will remain
very close to you talking to many of my
British colleagues and those British
friends this is what their vision is
also and we see this in the UN in the
European Union from a German perspective
Britain had always been very close to us
also when it comes to market economy
into free markets to free trade when it
comes to discipline also comes to his
role in security defense they bring
something to the table so Germany has
every interest to keep it close we were
nevertheless after the decision and
Chancellor was very unhappy about the
verse anus we don't have she has always
resisted all efforts in Germany to come
to referenda don't ask a question cannot
live with the answer I talked about and
the Alliance looking at our Constitution
we have representation of democracy so
this will not be disaster but that we
will stay together on a stupid tools
video I think we don't have an interest
in promoting a two-speed Europe because
if you will have then you know Europeans
in different configurations it is it is
very very difficult I think it's very
good for you to speak with one voice to
speak with 4:28 but the European
treaties allow for this to speak we
actually have it already now Europe you
have it with shiny and and so we will
have actually by fact how we have
corporation security defense 25 country
said we want to go for this area and so
you you will have practice kind of a
two-speed Europe but it's nothing that
would promote because in the end the
best fit would be for 28 countries
decided to stick together speak with one
voice and
hello thank you but can you hear me I
can't tell I'm thinking of the
reunification of Germany and I believe
Gorbachev was promised that NATO would
not be extended that's correct right
because I've heard the participants
discuss it I'm trying to ask a question
can I just continue as the question so
in any case we know NATO was extended to
the borders and I'm asking how do you
think that makes pute and feel about
dealing with the West when it comes to
having agreements and what kind of
threat does he see Kissinger said that
we're misunderstanding Putin in this
respect and I'm asking you to comment on
NATO's expansion and what kind of
instability that that could possibly
cause to clarify there was no reason
whatsoever yes this is always said
yes but this doesn't make it more true
if what is and actually forward to a
percentage himself that there was no
agreement there is one agreement and
that is that should be on the we don't
have there should be no permanent NATO
base in East Germany or the other
countries so that why all of Germany
belongs to to NATO there is no a NATO
base in East Germany the extension to
the to the borders and heating with the
West I mean I come back to the response
what I said earlier was report you pray
if the country that has lived under
Soviet oppression and I mean when you
look at the situation and the Soviet
Union what it meant for the for the
Baltic countries who were distinguished
I have of the Baltic population at left
you look at what how the Soviet Union
when they tried in in crack when they
tried in in Budapest in Hungary or even
in East Germany to to demonstrate and to
rid of a communist system how they
crushed that with attacks for these
countries to say now now we we are freed
of communism and we want to become a
member of NATO so that this doesn't
happen again in history I mean oh he
Germans were you to tell them no wait
for that you cannot become member be
defended by NATO so therefore we have
offered Russia after unification after
the end of the Cold War to work with to
work together with us we have been
nato-russia Council we have the
nato-russia founding Act where actually
we want to have a cooperative system
with Russia but this was not the
perspective that Putin had so he said
he's said that the worst whatever
happened was the end of the Soviet Union
and he thinks that
the vision for Russia should be to
reestablish somehow the Soviet Union and
I think we have to defend our freedom
and we have to defend the freedom of
those countries that lived under
oppression under the Soviet Union and we
have to defend that
what
well the instability you basically have
or those countries that are not member
of NATO so to speak and when you look at
Georgia when you look at Moldova Ukraine
you can see that Russia has taken over
parts of their countries and try to you
know have a foot in the door there and
to see to it that their influence the
development of they are so and this is
very very unfortunate so this is this is
happening
I
[Music]
well I'm not a spokesperson for the
European People's Party and I can only
see this from the from the outside when
you look at the European Party families
say that in all four the tablets you
have so to speak like sheep and there
are many parties member of these parties
have to calibrate what what they are
best to to handlers do keep them in the
party in the party family and exercise
some exercise some influence on them or
do you expel them and then they are
outside and then they may become very
very good part of majorities if you have
to fight and I say that so it's not for
me to respond to that it result of all
this is that when it comes to very tough
decisions in
you know when it counts for instance one
of the issues discussing the relations -
to Russia talk to the invasion in
Ukraine until now it hasn't always been
possible to get also Hungarian support
for the extension of the new sanctions
maintaining it particularly the
sanctions against Russia because of the
invasion yeah this is not this is not
automatic there are many doubt that but
when you're part of a family then it's
easier to get your family members to go
along with these decisions but then
right you have a very legitimate
question there in you know what the
party family stands for but what I want
to say that within you have members of
this but obvious senior members just in
all the party members a Christian
Democratic Party in Germany that's bad
for democracy the chairman of the CTU is
Chancellor Merkel
and I think one give up say that she has
thank you my name is Myron Melnick and I
have a question about Ukraine we know
that in recent years in the last four or
five years with the forceful annexation
of Crimea and the instability in
southeastern Ukraine we know that the
population in Ukraine has become very
security-conscious
and of course there is an existing
association agreement now with Europe
but recent polls indicate that solid
majorities now in Ukraine Eastern
Western central Ukraine are in favor of
further integration into Europe and
eventually in the EU and even healthy
majorities now have emerged in favor of
membership in NATO so this is a dramatic
change forced by the security concerns
in recent years so my question is what
impediments does Germany see towards
further integration of Ukraine into the
EU and maybe eventually into NATO and a
similar question with respect to the EU
what impediments exist for further
integration let's start with the
European Union
Ukraine over the last years has readily
come closer to the European Union you
remember in let me the question should
it have an association agreement or not
wrong to Maidan brought thee because
they then Yanukovych never decided
against that
and then the Maidan happened that a new
government was then voted that was in
favor of the association agreement so we
have the association agreement we have
visa liberalization so there have been a
number of steps taken at this stage on
the one hand European Union service very
dimension Union is very reluctant when
it comes to two new members and
digesting the last enlargement we were
horrible country so right now and there
is there is a certain reluctance and at
the same time there are the new treaties
where it says it
in country can and apply for membership
so this possibility is always there I
think that before Ukraine can become a
member a lot of things have to happen in
Ukraine and Ukraine is going into the
right direction but when it comes to the
to the to the rule of law and up to the
judicial system it comes to the fight
against corruption when it comes to good
governance there are still a lot of
steps to take and so EU membership is
not for for all but this u.s. cessation
agreement offers a lot of chances
through the integration into the
internal market so economically and I've
already seen a switch the orientation of
Ukrainian economy from
- - Eastern Europe and Russia for that
matter on on NATO the discussion about
Ukraine becoming member is an old one
there was already main subject at the
NATO summit in 2008 and the discussion
of Russian action plan was raised at the
time there is a there is a paragraph in
the NATO the NATO rules which which says
that each new member should contribute
to the stability of the organization and
what as a NATO member you don't want to
do is to bring within NATO a conflict
which could let's be very honest which
membership Ukraine and Ukraine could you
know invoke Article five as you have
made to fighting Russia over Crimea so
and this is something which right now is
on the agenda which does not mean that
with regard to training missions
exchanges between NATO and Ukraine have
a very increased over time
mr. massive you've been very generous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]